[Music]
oh hi
didn't see you guys over my 16-inch
macbook pro
today we're doing an ask ij episode i
haven't done one of these in so long
that's where you guys ask me questions
and i answer and all of these questions
i took from twitter
a ton of you asked me what i think of
the new macbook pro and obviously i love
it i'm going to be doing a bigger video
talking about it here very shortly but
so far it's been awesome it has stayed
so much cooler when i edit on my lap
and that little bit of screen real
estate has actually made a huge
difference when i'm editing in final cut
so i have been extremely
happy but let's get into the rest of the
questions where should i put this
i'm gonna put it off to here is that
okay i haven't done one of these in a
while so we're gonna start with this
first question from nicholas because
it's something that i'm extremely
excited about
and something that i've been wanting to
tell you guys for so long i did make one
video talking about it but i am doing a
conference
on january 31st and february 1st in los
angeles
we're calling it vlog university and for
those of you who have been a part of my
channel for
a really long time you might remember
it's something that i started about nine
ten years ago so next year 2020 is the
10 year anniversary of vlog university
what better way to celebrate a crazy
idea that i had when i feel like i was
still a child
is now a massive conference that we're
having in los angeles it's basically
going to be two days
filled with speakers incredible
instructors to basically teach you
everything that you need to know to
become a content creator so all the
things that you're going to be learning
about video editing production
lighting photography even makeup tips
script writing
what gear to get we have lawyers we have
people from my team my manager
my agents everyone kind of inside my
little ijustine bubble we're all going
to be there and giving you guys
some of the things that we've learned
over the past 13 years so to be able to
do this
to give back to you guys and to be able
to meet a bunch of you
who want to become future content
creators is honestly the craziest
coolest thing that i think that i will
ever be able to be a part of so i look
forward to seeing many of you guys there
check out vlog university for more
information and at checkout use
ijustine10 so that you can get a 10
discount if you do plan on attending
make sure you register before december
31st that way you will get not only a
free t-shirt but we will be able to have
a better sense of how many people will
be attending there's a lot of planning
that's going into this we've been
working on this for the past year and i
cannot
be more excited so nicholas thank you
for your question this is a really great
question from caitlin
and she's asking what is the biggest
thing that you've learned so far in your
career and what do you think the future
of youtube and content creators will be
i love this question because it kind of
segues very well from the vlog
university concept and
really what i wanted to do with that is
i wanted to give all of the knowledge
and the insight that i've learned over
the years and one of the biggest lessons
that i've learned i'm just going to give
it away here is
just keep going there's been so many
times throughout my career that i've
questioned what i'm doing i've
questioned myself i've questioned people
around me
and you just get to a point where you
have to just keep going like there's
always
something else that's going to happen
next you just have to kind of get to
that point and sometimes it's not easy
it can be extremely difficult
life can get in the way people can get
in the way but you just have to
i guess kind of trust yourself to know
that you're strong enough to keep going
you're strong enough to pave the way
for whatever it is that you want to do i
know it sounds absolutely crazy because
if i was sitting here
years and years ago listening to
somebody telling me these things i would
say you're crazy but until you sort of
live these life experiences or you get
to a point
where anything that i'm saying makes
sense it's not gonna make sense
answering your second question what do i
think of the future of youtube and
content creators will be i mean i have
no idea i just hope that
doing vlog university having fun events
and having a safe place where people can
talk make friends and find other people
in this industry that are doing the same
things as you are
is so amazing because when i started
there was nobody else doing this i had
no friends doing this everyone thought i
was crazy
i mean i definitely was because no one
else was doing this
everyone told me i should stop i
shouldn't do this i remember like one of
my old bosses at my job when i
quit my actual job he basically told me
that i was going to amount to nothing
and i basically
took that pain and anger as motivation
of like well you don't think i'm gonna
be anything well i'm gonna completely
prove you wrong so sometimes that
negativity can be completely flipped
around and you can use it to your
advantage did i answer your question
probably not and schillinger is asked
should i probably pronounce your last
name
am i ever going to do cooking videos
again you miss them i honestly do miss
them a lot but it kind of turned into
this thing where i used to use cooking
videos as
filler content between tech videos but
now i feel like this year there has been
so much tech that it's kind of taken
over for the cooking videos so i do plan
on doing some holiday videos so if
there's anything that you'd like to see
me bake for the holidays please please
please
leave it in the comments below and
hopefully i can make you some delicious
holiday delights this is a very
interesting
question from lachey all of my social
media links
state to be my friend there's a
difference in being a follower and a
friend
now will you consider changing it it's
crazy because in the beginning when i
first started doing this stuff
everyone was a friend i knew every
single person that was following me
because it was such a small community
and a small audience that everyone knew
each other i would recognize people's
avatars i would see the same people
tweet me all the time and
it's crazy because even though i do have
a bigger audience
i'm still reading my comments i'm still
on twitter even though i may not respond
to everything
i recognize the people who continually
tweet me i recognize people who comment
all the time so i sometimes think that
you guys don't think that i do read my
stuff but i do i'm here
all day on instagram on twitter with
that being said though i have cut back
significantly because i think that
through the years i was so focused on
social media that i wasn't living my own
life so i think that i have finally
found sort of a happy medium between
that i still definitely spend way too
much on my phone too much time on my
computer but i've cut back a lot
i guess to answer your question though
i'm not going to be changing it to
follower because i still
consider you guys friends owen is asking
what are my thoughts on the rumors of
the 2020 iphone 12
or is it too early oh my gosh it's
definitely not too early because i feel
like everything
in that 20 20 iphone has already sort of
been leaked i do remember last year
this design of the iphone was leaked in
like january
who really knows anymore let's see if
there's any latest
rumors iphone 2020 all right mac rumors
what have you guys got for me 5.4 6.7
6.1 sizes
triple lens a 3d camera with laser all
oled displays a 5g
revamped design a14 chip it's crazy they
have this
much potentially leaked information i
just think that
5g is it's going to be great but unless
it's in your area unless you're near
that tower like it's not
going to actually work very well so i'm
excited about 5g
but i don't think the technology is
really going to be ready i guess this is
by september of next year
from going along the same timeline as
this year and previous years
so yeah this is apple expected to
release the 2020 iphone 12
in september of 2020. under display
touch id i
don't think they will do that for some
reason i just really don't think that
they're
going to waste their time there's a lot
of other things that you can waste your
time doing like maybe a foldable phone
which i also don't think that they will
do the 20 20 iphone
i'm excited next question will i ever
wait in line for an iphone launch like i
did with the iphone 6 that was
such a crazy time if any of you guys
remember my sister and i slept outside
for like 50 some hours to get the iphone
6. this is back when the pre-orders were
such a struggle like nothing ever worked
properly
i just kept getting screwed trying to
get pre-orders from my iphone so when i
realized that i wouldn't have an iphone
for launch day
i asked my sister and some of my friends
if they wanted to sleep outside
and we did and it was an amazing
experience i definitely
don't think that i really ever want to
do that again but it's something that i
did
it's something that i experienced and i
really
don't ever want to have to do it again
it was fun
but i think in my old age i don't know
if i could handle it
alec is asking what do i do to make
myself feel better when you're feeling
sad
or depressed it's taken me years to
figure out
what i need for myself to make myself
feel better and sometimes
there's just no way out of it you just
have to kind of keep going keep moving
like i said before
just keep moving forward keep going
don't quit
what i found is it's definitely exercise
working out
finding activities to do to kind of
distract my mind from
you know feeling the way that i'm
feeling doing yoga going for hikes going
for walks just kind of getting out of my
element making myself
sort of feel uncomfortable but something
that i also started
almost a year and a half ago as i
started training in jiu jitsu and i have
not talked about this at
all on my channel so it's kind of weird
that i'm even
mentioning it i don't post about it i
don't talk about i don't think i've
never taken a single picture of myself
training but it's something that i do
for myself i don't do it for anyone else
and that has brought me this sort of
piece
and like this purpose outside of
creating content
out of posting on social media so find
something that
you do for yourself you don't do for
anyone else you don't do it for the
internet
you don't do it for your parents or your
boyfriend girlfriend sister
brother whatever you do it for you and
no one else
it's crazy because some of like my
favorite achievements even recently
are things that i've never even shared
milestones that i've made training
friends that i've made at the gym it's
just it's really crazy because
for my entire life i have posted
everything online like i've posted
so much so to just completely flip a
switch and decide that this is something
i'm doing
for me and not the internet it's
incredibly refreshing
so i encourage anyone whatever your
mindset whatever
you're going through find something find
a new hobby find something absolutely
just
completely out of your comfort zone and
go do it be uncomfortable
oh god i was uncomfortable for probably
like six months there's so many times
even now
after almost i guess training for almost
two years
i still every day sometimes i will leave
a session and i'm like
this is just it's so defeating but you
keep going it's a lot like life and i
think that's why i really really love it
one day
maybe i'll make a full video talking
about my experience but right now
it's still something that i'm doing for
me but i'm only mentioning this because
i want you guys to do something for
yourself and hopefully you guys will
have the same
incredible experience that i've had
doing this thing just for myself
vicki is asking what i think about
instagram hiding likes
and it's just i it doesn't even matter
anymore like i don't ever really even
look at likes anymore i mean i tend to
need them for brand deals or
for projects and things like that like
obviously people want to know i just
don't even care anymore i don't know if
it's because i've been doing this for so
long and i think i've just had the
realization that none of this actually
really matters that realization for me
has made me enjoy what i'm doing
so much more and instagram hiding them i
think it might be a good thing because
if you do tend to compare yourself to
people you compare yourself to people
who have more subscribers than you how
did this person get more likes on this
photo
what might not do as well as this
person's it's so so silly i mean there
was definitely a time you know doing
youtube and stuff like this that i just
started to stop
enjoying it it was maybe like five or
six years ago
i feel like it's every three years i
kind of have this cycle of yes yes yes i
love this oh shoot everything is just
falling apart and then
it kind of just keeps going back up so i
feel like not just with youtube
but with life and for everyone this
isn't just youtube i keep stressing that
because there's a lot of correlation
between
youtube people's careers whatever it is
that you're doing
it all is the same like just because i'm
sitting here talking to you making this
youtube video this is my job this has
become
something that is work and i'm so
grateful that i
really do enjoy it i've had some jobs in
the past that i didn't enjoy
and a lot of times you just have to do
what you have to do
just get it done and really just keep
thinking about
what is it that you're most passionate
about and how can you turn that
into a career how can you use that
passion to not only make money
but really enjoy your job it's
definitely not an easy thing and i think
eventually
if you're persistent enough and
passionate enough i fully believe
that you guys can do it and i know this
speaking from my own experience
and i truly believe that if there is
something that anybody wants to do if
they really want to do it bad enough
they're going to do it
i have faith in you guys i'd love to
hear from you though in the comments
what is the one thing that you want to
do what is something that you have done
that you're super proud of i'd love to
hear it william wants to know if we'll
ever get an updated officer this is
crazy because
i actually am working on one right now
so
when i saw this tweet i was like oh you
read my mind can't wait to show it to
you guys i've been waiting for one last
piece of my office and it was a tv so
spoiler alert that's kind of what the
video is going to be about but i can't
wait to show you the new office tour
it's been so much fun to sort of put
together
where i edit and where i spend a lot of
my days when i'm not traveling
because usually i'm sitting on a plane
editing on this computer well that looks
like that's all the questions we have
thank you guys so much for watching i
appreciate you
i feel like i don't do these types of
sit down videos as much anymore so if
you enjoyed this
please let me know and i look forward to
seeing you guys in the next video
bye
[Music]
you